concerns at the 2020 Olympic Games that
may be canceled because of the quickly
spreading coronavirus the Olympic flame
was lit this morning in Olympia Greece
the iconic ceremony was closed to the
public though because of the deadly
virus
the Tokyo games are just four months
away at this point in Iranian innocencio
reports from the new National Stadium in
Tokyo where the opening ceremony is
supposed to take place the clock is
ticking till Tokyo host the 2020 Summer
Games this July but Olympic dreams and
Olympic sized investments could both
fall victim to the coronavirus fireworks
in January heralded the return of the
Olympic rings to Tokyo but now with just
months left the fear is the games won't
even begin the new national stadium is
meant to be the grand centerpiece and
venue for the opening and closing
ceremonies
now this stadium was rebuilt from the
old national stadium at a cost of 1.4
billion dollars this was in fact the
site of the 1964 Tokyo Olympics it can
hold about 68,000 people but that may
never happen
that's because mass gatherings around
the world are getting canceled air
travel has also been hit hard with major
US airlines cutting flights to Asia the
two airports that serviced Tokyo that's
an arena as well as Haneda right here
have invested so heavily into upgrades
up to two million tourists are expected
to fly in for the Olympics
now Tokyo has to house all those
visitors and accommodations from hotels
to Airbnb s have already been booked at
a premium the famed okura Tokyo hotel
built just in time for the 1964 Tokyo
games spent an estimated 1 billion
dollars for a complete teardown and a
total rebuild just in time for the Tokyo
2020 Olympics other major costs are
sponsorships and broadcast rights
American companies shelled out about one
and a quarter billion dollars for
television ads exclusive rights to the
games cost reported 1.4 billion
and if the games were canceled the
world's third-largest economy would take
a hit the probability of recession is
very high yes / Cole has been tracking
Japan's economy for the past three
decades what would be the best case and
worst case scenarios if the Olympics
were cancelled look I mean first of all
if the Olympics got cancelled because
the coronavirus is running out of
control trust me we'll have bigger
things to worry about than just the
negative impact from the Olympics
we'll be worrying about a global
depression in the economic sense of the
word but also in the emotional for the
15000 Olympic and Paralympic athletes
who are supposed to fly to Japan this
summer all that sweat could turn to
tears if they were to cancel it would be
US Olympian will clay won two silver
medals in the triple jump at both London
2012 and Rio 2016 now training in Santa
Monica California for 2020 he tells CBS
News a fleet SAR being assured the games
are a go
I think the Olympics could show the
world and unite the world and so when
that things will be okay we're coming
together and we're gonna fight this
thing now the last time the Olympics
were canceled was back in 1944 for World
War two if the games get canceled this
year or even postponed it would be the
first for a global pandemic
Tokyo's mayor says that is unthinkable
Japan's Olympics chief says that is
inconceivable at least for now for CBS
this morning Rainey Inocencio Tokyo
inconceivable until it's not for now
yeah the key phrase there I mean I think
you've got to be looking at everything
and anticipating anything at this point
yes and bright in the middle of the
summer July 24th through August 8th a
lot of people look into those day it's a
million tourists if they don't show up
that is a big impact economic impact is
devastating